[Music]
okay let me start with the most
important thing I'm still happy to be
able to help you promote this
documentary thank you so much for coming
in before we get started the only reason
Collider gets to be at the Toronto
International Film Festival is because
of sponsors I want to give a huge thank
you to Nordstrom Canada for allow for
being a great sponsor and for allowing
us to cover movies like this it's
expensive you know to cover fests I
think you've probably heard the rumors
even making movies so I have a million
questions for you guys but the first is
I just want to say thanks for making
this movie it's such a great story and
so powerful and I think that one word I
took away after I finished is inspiring
you know to remind people that this is
possible you know which I think so many
people lose track of you know all the
time but so since most people not have
seen the movie yet I hate asking the
generic question but can you talk a
little bit about what the film is about
the film is about a faraway country
called Armenia for me it always played
out like a fairy tale it's almost like
once upon a time in a faraway land a
group of rulers control the country and
they grew richer and richer and they
grew more powerful and more powerful and
the people lived in poverty and then one
day one man her husband mrs. Hawkins
husband a man by the name of Nicole
pacinian and a small group of followers
and a stray dog they decided they were
gonna walk across the country and in a
matter of 40 days realize a revolution
against the most powerful rulers that
that country had ever known and
everybody said this was absolutely
ridiculous until the revolution came to
life in one of the most splendid and
inspiring spectacles that any revolution
could hope to achieve
now mrs. Hawkins husband is the Prime
Minister of the Republic of Armenia mrs.
Jaco peon while she's declined the title
of first lady actually so we'll call her
a philanthropist and the editor of the
Armenian times one of the big newspapers
of Armenia it is everything about this
story is so crazy because as I said I
think off camera if you wrote this as a
Hollywood screenplay
what
this what happens no one would make this
movie because they would say it's too
unbelievable so um I guess I guess talk
a little bit about how you got involved
let's start with that how did you get
involved in this whole thing so Nikolas
Union while he was in the square he was
encouraging diaspora and Armenians
Armenians who don't live in Armenia to
come back home because this was a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to see
people elated you know at the prospects
of driving their own dreams imagining
living their own visions as a country
you know as a populist and so I went and
when I was there got in and I hooked up
and he was already shooting a lot of
stuff that was happening and and and we
just got him up we we realized the
importance of the message we realized
that irrespective of press covering the
event BBC al-jazeera etc being at the
revolution we realized most people
outside of Armenia are not going to know
that in 40 days a post-soviet oligarchic
corrupt regime was completely this you
know displaced by a progressive new
government without one bullet being
fired without one person dying and in in
a revolutionary tactic known as
decentralized civil disobedience that's
historically unique and never been used
and we knew that there was a story here
that was so special that it had to be
told as soon as possible as I said I I
really mean this to anyone watching
right now I at some point this will be
available for people to see and I just
so recommend this one just to please
seek it out so talk a little bit about
when did you realize you wanted to start
filming this thing when did you realize
this something special is happening a
change has been impossible in Armenia
for decades we've been on the street
nikohl pacinian has been on the street
Sarah Tonkin has been on the street on
the hakko pin is but we've been fighting
for this and failing at this for decades
I have thousands of hours of footage of
failed revolutions in in piles and piles
of drives so if you want the honest
answer for me I had no
via this was going to succeed I thought
wow another social movement has started
I'm gonna pick up my camera like I
always do because I have nothing better
to do or because I'm compelled to the
faith and the possibility of the magic
that we all felt and that was the thing
by every analysis by every intelligent
evaluation of the scene this was not
possible you're saying Hollywood
wouldn't greenlight a movie that's true
in the political analysis - it was the
same thing you can't
it was pure idealism pure faith against
the all-powerful regime so to believe
that this was actually going to happen
no way and yet at the same time in our
heart of hearts it was inevitable we
didn't know when it was going to happen
but we knew the eruption of the magic
would one day come and it finally came
in March and April of last year it is I
have to ask you when this whole thing
must be so crazy but when did you
realize at what point in this journey
did you realize because it's on film but
when did you realize this something's
really happening here do you know that
what what has this been like for you to
be honest I realized that this time my
husband and our nation they wield will
win when even know nothing has started
yet just my husband told us in an
evening a nice evening that he is going
to start a movement against a serf
saxons
a third turn and I realized that time
that this is what we have we must do and
this time he will succeed I don't know
why but I I believed in it and the
further processes showed that I was
right because you know because he won't
wait what's amazing is I am so
I don't know what the right word is what
your husband did and the willingness of
him to put himself in harm's way again
and again take such courage that I don't
know if I have that kind of courage and
I don't think most people have that kind
of courage what is it like for you
watching him do these things being so
fearless and just I'm so in awe of what
he did that is why I love him so much
and I became his wife when we met first
time this is not new for me with this
revolution the whole world knows now
about him about his courage about his
faith and other other very very delicate
positive positive things but I knew it
from the first days I met him and that's
why I decided to be with him to be next
to him in whole journey and I knew from
the first days that he will be in prison
one day that he will face a lot of
difficulties in our life because because
he was going to this whole during whole
life just I'm with him I'm not following
him just from apart and with him in all
this way I would imagine you had a
tremendous amount of footage so how long
was your first cut of this film versus
what people will finally see you'll see
a lean mean 90 minutes hopefully
riveting it started off at about two and
a half hours I would say the first cut
that that we liked and with the help of
a really masterful editor named Barry
Poulter man who cut films like Jim and
Andy we got this to something that we
all think is quite compelling and quite
cool no completely you you did music I
did write I'm curious when did you start
writing and did you were you writing
when the two-and-a-half hour cut existed
like you know Mika's yeah I'm just
curious about the writing process be
honest says yeah no we we actually
started with this song that Negro
passion had
and the revolution song which is called
I am not alone the name of the film
and so hikes fed is the name of the
artist who sang it in Armenia and so we
we were lucky enough to have rights to
the song so we were playing around with
remix ideas and all this stuff before we
even had a cut to do the score too but I
think we started a little we started a
little earlier the orderly search
I always start early I always started
late because I don't know what else I've
got going on you know there's all
there's always stuff going on so I
started as early as I can to get as much
work ahead of time as I can we started
before final cut earlier and we did a
bunch of stuff and then we migrated
queues and then kept on writing more and
more got in and I work very closely came
to my studio and to go through a lot of
stuff and that was very helpful you know
working with a great director who knows
exactly what he wants and what works and
what doesn't work that kind of feedback
is always very very productive obviously
so I think I think we have a really good
score to kind of highlight the positive
vibe of the film the the kind of magical
kind of result of this 40-day revolution
in a way that's never happened in
history it's it's amazing I have to ask
you what percentage of the revolution do
you think is responsible
I forget the dog's name chalo chalo how
much do you think cello is responsible
for the revolution and I would like a
real percentage I'm thinking a good 15%
now am I wrong about this good is at 5%
I don't think that cello is responsible
for revolution but but I wanted to give
an information he is living now at our
house and he's doing well and his role
is he is a symbol here but but these
symbols were important yes it was all
about creating a sense that a fairytale
is happening the entire visual of this
man with a backpack and almost 12
followers walking across the same
country with a stray dog kind of joining
them along the way
there was always the sense that it was
almost it was almost a movie being made
to be you know sort sort of being born
and so I do think that Chavo I'm sorry
to disagree with you
but as a very strong supporting make no
mistake I I the only thing I've learned
let's I'm going to use the term have you
seen a movie called John wick right John
wick so there is a in the movie which is
cannibal awesome just fantastic Keanu
Reeves plays a hitman and he's a retired
hitman but they go after his dog they
kill his dog the entire rest of the
movie is him destroying and killing
people because they killed his dog and
there's an emotional hit that comes from
that dog that you cannot it's so
different than a person and I know this
sounds so crazy but when people animals
really resonate with people right and
and I know I'm messing around a little
bit but I actually think you know people
love animals well no there's the whole
save the cat theory right if you want
your hero to be liked by the audience
you have him save a cat in the first 10
minutes of the film it's the save a cat
theory in our case we substitute
substituted for a dog and I think it
worked out quite I do have to say one
thing my favorite part of the movie it's
a movie so I have to talk about it as a
movie but my favorite part of the movie
is when Neagle and all the other guys
got arrested and Anna was put in a
situation where she had to do something
that she felt was out of character for
her which is you know get up there and
speak publicly and and and kind of her
Lennon Azaria and some of you know who's
an MP and and really really stand up for
Armenia to me when I'm watching the film
that's when I really kind of just
emotionally just kind of to me that's an
emotional climbers that's so I I think
you know I'll shallow jokes aside there
were besides nigo who was very very
obviously instrumental there are amazing
people around him like Anna like Lena
like Arad and and all these other
revolutionaries that fought with him and
and advised them and worked with them
and did a phenomenal job at really
realizing this
all together for all of Armenia sure one
of the things I also think is so
important about the movie is that with
it is so important that something like
this can can happen because what's
happening on the planet right now it's
just you think in 2019 I thought as a
kid 2019 we are gonna be like Star Trek
and so advanced and like everyone's
gonna get like it's gonna be at a bit
more advanced society and I feel like
we're going backwards in in like
fast-forward backwards in terms of the
way we treat each other and the way the
planet operates and so I think it's so
important for people to see your story
and realize what we can do you know I
always I always say by the percentage
that we saw in Armenia if that many as a
percentage of population of that many
people came out onto the streets of biet
Washington DC or you name the capital or
you name the country it would have an
incredible impact effect politically on
that country I mean in the u.s. that
would be 30 million people blocking
streets peacefully and asking Trump or
whoever you'd like to resign I know that
I could tell that got you excited but
you know that's what I'm talking it's
it's an incredible power powerful thing
that I think this revolution kind of
happened upon it's a it's it's something
that's never been historically done and
I keep on bringing that point up because
I feel like it's revell not just the
revolution itself but the act of itself
was revolutionary sure I have to ask so
your premier what day do you premiere
here today and if hours oh wow
okay no but no pressure no no anything
so what is the plan to show the movie in
our media is that you have is it is it
part of a you have a strategy is it
being bought and like how is it working
hopefully we'll learn more in a few
hours this this will be the first
audience for our film and our whole you
know agenda and goal is to find the
right partners to to bring this story to
a global audience so that's part of the
reason why we're we're at TIFF and we
really believe in this story with we
think it has the
a real magic to it and we hope to find
the right kind of distributor or partner
to help us bring this to the world I
absolutely hope that I listen that this
story is so incredible and what you all
brought to the screen is so well told
and I can't imagine someone not wanting
to you know thank you you know what I
mean um listen I could ask you a million
other things but I know you have to do
other press and the point is we'll talk
again at some point hopefully I'm just
gonna say I really mean it
your film is fantastic inspiring thank
you for what you did please thank your
husband and say and pass on how brave I
think he is and thank you for making
this movie